eux nous aurons nous avons ici n'est ce
pas un petit problème qui est un
problème culturel
nous avons le problème qu en effet comme
disait monsieur boda très justement en
chine on n'aime pas tué on n'aime pas
répandre le sang
alors il ne reste plus qu'un seul moyen
c'est ma rééducation ça peut vous
paraître avoue terrible mais qu'est-ce
qui est le plus terrible est ce que
c'est de liquider les gens oui ce que
c'est de essayer de leur faire voir et
non pas par des choses fort c'est comme
les gens le raconte
mais en leur donnant tout le temps eu
même de lire de se rendre compte de ce
qui se passe et leur donner le temps de
réfléchir à certains problèmes problèmes
personnels problème de réintégration
dans la société afin qu un homme inutile
de désabusé désespéré qui prétend mettre
le suicide ou un criminel ou quelqu'un
d'autre soit réhabilité en parle
beaucoup en amérique de la
réhabilitation des gens des prisonniers
de leur réintégration dans la société
la chine le fait est alors on dit mais
c'est terrible mais dans tous les pays
du monde aujourd'hui on s'interroge sur
copains faute cela confère des
prisonniers des handicapés sociaux
que va-t-on faire de ces gens qui sont
des asociaux des anormaux la chine le
fait est bien elle le fait peut-être
d'une façon qui ne vous plaît pas mais
elle le fait